hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
mill is one of these these thinkers
who's defending is his favorite approach
by the time that mill is on scene people
have been making arguments and
utilitarianism is a bad thing
that's what you can see it as a tract
they don't criticize usually so the
middle is going to make a claim that all
these other normal theories that are
available as options for figuring out
what's right and wrong good and bad how
we ought to behave what a full life
looks like and how we want to order the
goods that are lies all those sorts of
things what kind of people we ought to
be he's saying that all of them when
they look at them closely enough insofar
as they are moral theories they boil
down utilitarians that's a pretty big
claim ISM that's that's like saying this
is the general theory of everything does
he address every moral theory that's
available not really he addresses some
of the ones that are
in his time so let's look at those and
then let's think about some of the other
moral theories that we might be studying
an argument using he talks about what he
calls me intuitive he says that this is
a priori and what all octree already
means in this case is we all sort of
agree on it because of being human
beings it doesn't come to us from
experience it's sort of born into us
it's part of our hardware so to speak
we're gonna look at things this way and
the intuitive theory says that no right
wrong
who's that sense for there's different
variations variations on this some of
the people doing evolutionary biology
stuff these days are making claims kind
of like that the vocabulary sometimes
changes so that we speak less in terms
of sympathy which is a very popular word
back that and more in Chinese and the
fee that's the popular word these days
the basic idea is that we have some sort
of moral sense I think that some people
brought conscious during the during you
know these classes some people's
versions of what conscience looks like
would it be like this you just you just
know what's right you just know what's
wrong you can just sort of look at
things now that's a tough sell to begin
because if that's the case how do people
end up doing that maybe they ignore
it's taken sometimes about their inner
voice is saying mill says in so far as
this theory is actually getting anything
right it's going to look pretty much
like until attorney is like the greatest
happiness principle think about some of
the things that that your your inner
voice if you buy it this way your sense
of right line without you never even
think about it would tell you good and
things that would tell you are bad so
you're presented with an opportunity to
steal something that's something that
you really are doing that you would get
pleasure from having the stuff and at
the same time it belongs to somebody
else
okay it probably would be pretty hurt by
you taking it's not just a little candy
bars or something like that maybe it's a
laptop right imagine if somebody maybe
have laptops how much would you lose
with somebody stole your laptop do you
back things up regularly on an external
hard drive
we're in Dropbox no yeah you know after
you lose a couple things computer
crashes you start doing that because you
lose so many valuable things maybe was
somebody took you even with mine backed
up somebody took my laptop I would be
like put out for a lot of things because
it's invaluable for so many functions
now you know how do you know what you
wanted steal somebody else's laptop well
think about things in terms
yeah I guess you can go back to and be
like you know what it's like to have
something stolen from you hmm okay now
what are you empathizing found a
empathizing about the sense of rage that
would come with it probably now happened
I would be furious I'm sure somebody
else would be furious what when we talk
about empathy we mean like feeling what
somebody else would be feeling what are
you yeah okay sense of loss anything
else
loss is a kind of pain it's painful to
lose and you know that it would be
causing somebody else paying now it
doesn't get you that far though how do
you know that it's wrong to cause other
people pain what if you get into that
steal everybody's laptops well you know
you would need something here's what
Milton you would need something like
utilitarianism like the greatest
happiness principle which says we want
to try to create the greatest amount of
happiness possible over all pleasures
and some pains you need something like
that to give you that extra step
wouldn't you because somebody can say
yeah I am I you know I steal your laptop
I know exactly what you're gonna feel
that's exactly why I'm stealing your
laptop in order to get the idea that
that's wrong we need something else
coming in and giving us information that
maybe this intuitive sense would do that
how do you know that saving the drowning
child sit there make a t-chart I hope I
jump in and my clothes on have to take
it to the dry cleaners
how do you there's no well you know the
bill say you rely on something like this
to figure that out you know you guys are
all familiar with the trolley problem
this infamous trolley problem yes it's
not really more like intuitive or is
that more like the fact that we value a
human life well if you buy into this
intuitive theory then we just wouldn't
feel right it would be one of our
intuitions and that but if you're
utilitarian and say well we value the
life because humans could feel pain and
pleasure pleasure responsible pain harm
trolley problems would be something that
might call for this sort of thing
trolley problem works like this there's
a trolley it's on a track it's going
real fast if you don't stop it in some
way then it's going to run over five
people and kill them it's going to
inflict harm on them the only way that
you can stop it there's different
variations by pushing like a big fat guy
waffle bridge onto the tracks or
sometimes it's you have some trolley
going a different way it kills somebody
else but you have to sacrifice one
person or let the trolley roll over five
feet what do you do that's where the
situation do you do you have to think
about that or do you sort of
automatically say 1vs5 in the picture
[ __ ] if you do then you'd be good to
latarian utilitarian shouldn't have any
problem with that because obviously
greatest happiness right five people
saving five people's but it's a one
person and that could be something but
if it is Millis think it's gonna really
be based on us he also talks about what
he calls the
inductive theories and these just mean
ones that we learned from experience you
know what what is right what is wrong we
figured out what works out better you
know so let's just put them over some
simplification those trial them how do
you know what's good to do try doing
different things to what happens like
how do you know that you shouldn't how
the little kids learn that they
shouldn't hit people pretty much what
they do they hit people when they get
anything you know and then they have
things happen to them sometimes they get
punished sometimes they they you know
hit somebody because they're angry and
then they don't like the fact that the
other person is now hurt and that
person's crying or perhaps angry and
won't be friends with them and cringes
when they come by and they don't like
that sort of thing right and then they
say I shouldn't hit people how do you
know that you should how do you know
it's a good things didn't give people
thanks gifts all right let's take
gifting when you were a kid when you
have to go to birthday parties and bring
gifts
just imagine like you wanted that gift
you're giving the option of like maybe
I'll keep the good gift and I'll give
them the crap gift how do you learn that
that's not what you want to do there
really got to sacrifice how do you how
do you learn if you have to pay for it
yourself
if I'm going to get so many gift I
should give them a gift that they would
actually like and you'd be willing to
spend the money on it rather than just
buying the first thing I can see at the
gas station
how do you figure that up well you try
it off see how that works out for you
see whether that person wants to be
friends does it visit continues now give
good gifts see what that Sun mill says
you can do that but what basis do we
make those decisions pain and pleasure
and greatest happens many things up
somebody else to learn and study over
the course of the semester
let's just call this an again over
simplifying let's just call the duty or
you should according to Kant's theory
your motivation for doing the right
thing ought to be doing the right thing
not than anything good in terms of
consequences comes out of it
you know it's the right thing because
you can actually perform certain tests
on the action that you're going to do
you can say could I will that this
action that I'm engaging in be a
universal law of nature so everybody
ought to do this everybody ought to
behave in the same way it's
universalizing
can I actually will that and no points
on problem that a lot of people have
brought up with Cox views which is that
once you actually start looking at you
know his justifications it does seem
like he does bring consequences in there
like how do you know that you shouldn't
live in a world that you don't then what
not stay hit people when you're angry
that hit that being angry is not a
justification well you could join the
universal I say everyone when they're
angry shall hit the personal anger that
does that make sense to little that sort
of universe should be universal why's
that so I had every time--that student
you know like for instance you don't do
your your assignment on time you make
being she gives you that make sense I
don't think it even makes sense but
let's say it good let's say we could
imagine a world like that I say
something in class you don't like you
get up get me it'd be a very strange
class but let's say that becomes the
norm right every time anybody gets angry
together would you want to live in a
world like that once you're really into
hitting people and don't mind getting
hit would you want to live in a world
like that now but they are you talking
about concert
aren't you and why would those be bad
consequences because you don't like
people hitting it causes pinion right
yeah even if you like get off of hitting
people like some people do like I think
maybe the cast of Jackass they might get
it but really most people wouldn't
because it's painful to get hit and even
painful to hit people after a while and
it might estranged us from each other
and you know you get through all sorts
of bad consequences that would be
evaluated by the greatest happiness
principle
so if midlas right than what we're all
doing at bottom is acting like
utilitarians so why don't we just peel
the mask off and just say we articulate
areas but that's all just use the
greatest happiness principle instead of
doing all this window dressing stuff
that's one of the arguments that he's
making whether or not that's really
persuasive you have to figure that
myself I don't actually consider it our
space would but I'd like you to think
now so yeah that's what he needs that's
pretty powerful stuff